dead serious about let's I know that I
was talking to the flight attendant
about this unamerican I tell her I was
gonna do this and she finally told me to
sit down yeah said to prepare she had to
prepare service she thinking she goes I
gotta get the card out and I said well
listen I had a great flight attendant to
an American real real real dark lady I'm
like I paid $40 for a more more space
heat she goes we don't have any so
you're so I'm in the blast seat of the
plane with her so so she gets because
you might get a refund I'll send you
some free miles I got uh she goes you
think you're having a bad day she
because I wasn't even supposed to be on
this flight because the flight attendant
who was her husband killed herself
they've been married two years and he
killed himself in his ex-wife's garage
and I'm like okay do we have the cheese
plate what are the snacks okay I said to
her we start talking she goes the other
day we took off we hit windshear when we
took off because you hit windshear the
whole plane goes to the side she goes
there was a scream she could say but she
used these words she goes it was a
blood-curdling scream as the plane took
off she was we got about maybe 3,000
feet up and it's just one and she was
the pilot got on right away and was a
caged wind shear we're gonna be okay um
and I said there I go yeah we're just
[ __ ] like they call it ferrying the
plane when nobody's on them like ever
just go up to first class when you got
nobody on the plane she goes she smiled
she was yes just one time we're all got
to sit in first class one time we had
four people on this plane we all got to
go right into the front sit in first
class I was at when was that she goes
four days after 9/11 with a big smile on
her face
the thing about flight attendants is
they don't they've made peace with death
because it's a very unnatural job to
just work 30,000 feet in the sky all of
those flight attendants they've seen
death they all do drugs they all do
these they have these stopovers they all
get hammered and all the pilots do drugs
it's a horrible job we don't pay those
people and it's a living hell they live
in an absolute hell and they have to get
on every day and go
hi welcome is everyone happy we're going
to Phoenix everyone excited we're going
to fannia Southwest can dress it up all
they want and they can have the people
come out and try to do stand-up and the
pilots try to be funny and the flight
attendants try to be funny but I know
what it really is I know it's a bunch of
people who've made peace with death
that's who works on planes